Hi Jp.
I'm wondering how the computer program that rates university courses as
worthwhile or not.
It's coming along well.
It isn't rating them as worthwhile.
It's rating them as postmodern Neil Marxist or not and it's actually fully
developed.
I was going to launch it and I didn't,
I didn't design it.
Uh,
somebody volunteered to design it and presented it to me and it seems to work
very well.
Um,
I was going to launch it at the end of August so that this year's university
students could benefit from it.
But there was the Charlottesville event and then I got busy and I also wasn't
feeling great and so I just didn't hit the window of time properly.
But I hope to be able to launch it for the January incoming class to do a video
about what's wrong with the university system,
that many things that are wrong with the university system and to launch the
website at the same time.
Also had people suggest to me that maybe it wasn't a good idea that it would
increase polarization,
but I've thought about that for about a month and a half.
And I think that the benefit to the consumer,
so that would be the informed student outweighs any danger of polarization.
And besides that,
something has to be done because the situation in the universities is really
ridiculous.
So,
okay.
All right,
so let's see what else we've got here in the chat room.
D.
E v.
Three.
That's quite a mouthful.
Says I'm studying to be a teacher,
but I'm also an introvert.
Could this be a big problem?
Can I still be a successful teacher?
Actually,
what seems to predict success at teaching best is intelligence and
conscientiousness.
That's the data so far.
So if you're conscientious,
then you'll probably be fine.
I mean,
x extra introverts have a harder time speaking in front of groups,
but you can learn to do that.
You know,
an introvert can become a very successful public speaker.
May Not enjoy it the same way that an extrovert might.
But that doesn't mean that you can't learn the skills.
And what I would recommend for an introvert is the same thing that I do when I'm
lecturing is I never talked to the whole group.
You know,
it doesn't matter how big the crowd is,
I'm always picking out individuals in the group and talking specifically to
them.
So I'll make a point to an individual and I watched their face and see if
they're nodding and understanding right?
Because that way you make contact with the entire audience and then you know,
all talk to someone for about 15 seconds or so.
I don't want to put them on the spot too much.
And then I shift my attention to someone else and I sort of pinpoint around the
room and that keeps everybody in the room focused on what I'm saying because
each person reflect the entire crowd back to you.
And so I would say if you're an introvert or if you want to speak in public in
general,
forget about the damn crowd.
It doesn't exist.
Speak to people one on one.
At a time and an introvert can do that just fine.
So,
you know,
that's where your strength would be.
And I would say you're,
you're much more likely to be unsuccessful as a teacher if you don't work hard
at it.
And if you're not interested in it.
So if you're an introvert,
I wouldn't worry about that.
Um,
I don't think that that will be the biggest problem that you'll face.
So.